Hello, oh fuck.
Okay, sorry, ignored the text.
Um, hello, give me a sec.
Oh, I hear myself.
Oh my god.
Okay, sorry.
Um, I'm a little dead inside as you guys can tell already.
You're gonna listen, you're gonna hear why I've been a little dead inside any minute now.
This little fucker.
Okay, Ducky Averdige has been a little- oh, there he goes.
Very fucking good.
I'm having my little- my lunch.
My lunch right now.
Yes, I'm having my lunch right now.
Okay, oh my god.
Please.
Okay, I love him.
I love him.
I love him so much.
He is the love- he is the love.
I love him.
He has done nothing wrong.
I love him so much.
I'm- I'm gonna freak out.
Okay, I love- I love you!
Okay, anyway.
I'm sorry, guys.
Okay, um.
I have to do- deal with this.
I had a chance to sleep for- I had a chance to sleep for 40 minutes and then
this fucker- I love you, but like- Oh my god.
Last week- oh my god.
I- I swear- I'm gonna get it.
I will get the collar.
I will get- I don't turn it on but he freaks out about it because it's- he has like PTSD from when he was younger because like it was really bad when he was a lot younger.
It was really bad.
So like I don't turn it on but he gets PTSD and I will get that.
I will get it.
I will fucking get it.
I- okay.
Okay, oh he knows.
Fucking better know.
Oh my god.
Anyway, so I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for being late today.
I had 40 minutes to nap before this stream and I was like, that's all right.
I can deal with 40 minutes.
This- oh.
I'm gonna grab it.
I'll be right back.
I still want to eat my food.
I gave you a warning.
You had a warning.
Okay.
All right.
Hello, everybody.
I am fighting back.
It's okay.
So I was like, I have 40 minutes.
He's not back yet but like I have the collar on my desk.
Just- oh.
Oh, you see that?
That's right.
Turn around.
Okay.
Oh, you see this?
Oh, that's right.
Turn around.
Yeah.
Walk away.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
All right.
He walked away.
Yeah.
Anyway, so.
So, um, I was like, okay.
I have 40 minutes before, um, before the stream.
I was like, I can't be that- I can- I can take that nap.
I'm- I've napped worst hours.
So I was like, I'll be fine.
There's 40 minutes.
By the way, this is like my first meal.
That's what I'm eating right now.
I'm so tired.
I didn't get to eat before my first stream.
I just went straight to bed.
So this is my first meal and I'm- I just basically cut some bread.
And with some brie cheese right now.
So this is like my snack before my actual meal.
So.
I was like, that's fine.
And then for 30 minutes straight,
Doki Amber Doge was like, you know what?
I've been able to push my boundaries the last week.
So maybe I can make her feed me two hours early than his regular feeding time.
Two hours early.
And I was like, no, you are not getting food early.
I'm- I'm gonna sleep.
And he was like, bet one of us will fold.
And it was me because I did not expect him to bark for 30 minutes straight while I was in bed.
And he would just- he would bark beside the bed.
He would bark at the door, like the door to the bedroom.
And he's like, one of us will break down and it's not gonna be me.
And he was right.
He was so right.
I- I was like, he'll get tired.
He'll- Eventually he'll get tired.
There's no way.
Because like, if you guys didn't know, if you guys didn't know, in- for dog training, you're supposed to like, just let them bark themselves out until they're tired.
So like, because you want to like, establish the fact that like, you know, they can't get like, they couldn't- they- oh, I did.
I- I like, hold- held it.
Like, I- I threw in the collar, but he didn't care at that point.
He was like, I'm hungry!
Now he's like, you know what?
I'm not that hungry.
So that's why it's working now.
Because he's like, oh, you're right.
I'm not really that hungry.
But that- back then, he was like, I'm willing to risk it all.
I'm- I'm willing to risk it all.
I don't care if you held that collar in front of me.
And so, you're supposed to let them bark until like, they- they realize they can't get anything out of it.
So I tried to do that, you know.
I tried- I was like, it's fine.
I- I- it's fine.
I'll just let him bark until he realized that he can't just demand anything he wants by just barking.
And he did it for 30 minutes straight.
He did it for 30 minutes straight.
And by the time he was done, I realized it was 440.
I realized it was 440.
Or like, no, it wasn't 4- I realized it was 445.
And I was like, oh.
I was like, I can't- I can't- you win.
You fucking won.
I can't- I can't do this any longer.
You won.
And so, the moment I got up, he knew he won too.
He knew.
I got up, and I was like, I got up, and then- and then- and then he was like, ha ha ha.
He was so happy, excited.
He's like, yeah!
And he did like a victory lap around me.
He was like, just running- like, he- he was just running around, and he's like, yeah!
Woo woo yeah!
And he did- and I just- I just slowly walked over to the food, and gave him his food, and he knew that- that fucker knew he won.
Oh my god.
That's why I'm messaging chat.
I was like, guys, I need 30 more minutes to nap.
I'm so sorry.
I- I'm so sorry.
He won.
Guys, you don't under- the- the worst part is- is that wiener dogs have the loudest barks out of like, all dogs.
They're like, the top five loudest barks, like, in the world.
And like, I would have been fine if he was any other dog, but he's so loud.
He's so loud.
You can't sleep through it.
You can't.
Oh my god, they're so tiny, but so very loud.
You have to listen to that.
I don't care if my neighbors heard that.
I- I'm sorry to my neighbors that had to listen to that for 30 minutes.
I'm sorry.
I just- I try to teach him, but he taught me.
He fucking taught me, guys.
So yeah, um, that's why I'm late.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for being late.
I- I really needed that extra sleep, um, because like, they weren't- for those who are not members- oh, he's coming back.
He's coming back.
Oh, see this?
That's right.
You see this?
Walk away.
I'm not done eating.
He walked away.
Get back.
He's underneath my desk now.
He's looking at me.
Oh my god.
He did nothing wrong.
I hope one day you own a wiener dog.
I hope- I hope one day- I hope one day you get a wiener dog.
Okay, here's a fun fact about wiener dogs.
They're very bratty.
They have a lot of personality and like- Like, they get what they- they- they know what they want and they get it.
They have- oh my god, they're- they have like one of the biggest personalities out there.
We're such a tiny little man.
They're so fucking tiny, but they're like, I might be tiny, but I'm the leader of this pack.
So like, he knows and he knows it.
He fucking knows it.
Alright guys, I'm almost done with my food.
I'm almost done.
Look at that.
He's been so quiet.
He's been so quiet ever since I showed him the collar.
I just gotta give him a little trauma for some peace and quiet.
Just a little bit.
He knows.
He fucking- yeah.
Iphan, Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
Finally, boy time.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alucard, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Boy, we must be better.
And Doki, get your protein, carbs for energy and health.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Unlucky, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I used to have a doxin when I was younger, so I know exactly what you mean.
You two be like that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I saw someone's chat was like you should get Oh, you should totally get two.
I always thought about getting two dogs But then if I get two dogs And they're both like this.
I Know I won't have a life anymore so
It will become their life I would merely exist for them
So like I was like maybe not
Yeah, I would definitely like I would definitely just like My whole life was throughout would be like revolving around them.
Oh Oh, you're getting a little confident now, aren't you?
Yeah You're a little confident, aren't you?
Well, I finished eating so you can leave now Tokyo Abrados You can leave now food is gone Food is now gone.
Goodbye Be gone Be gone you demon Be fucking gone
He's just sitting there Toki Don't do this All right, guys.
It's time.
It's time to play our favorite game everybody.
You know what it is You know what it is guys Yeah Where I got you guys No, we're not guys no, no, no, I don't know where you got the idea.
I Don't know where you got the idea that we're playing God
I'm joking.
I'm really I've got a word I'm Hey,
yeah All right now now we have the real game
Hey Marvel rivals update dope for like twitch rivals.
So you guys didn't know.
Um, I talked about it during the member stream.
I talked about during the member stream and Um the Marvel rivals twitch rivals will be Saturday like literally next Saturday on the 18th.
So it's actually really close by and we're gonna be like we're trying to min-max our team Because we really want to get to the finals So our team is basically three people from Um the from the from the second place team of the Marvel rivals Tournament and it's gonna be me me super Gomez hogs and Ry amazing and those three are actually in the same team together for and they won like first place in several other tournaments for my Rivals and they won like they got second place for the recent ones.
So What are Cuz we're only allowed maximum four players or above Diamond so it was me.
It was a very hard decision because I got to pick the entire team.
So So I get to pick whichever like which one I can get from the entire team and it was a very hard decision but I decided to pick up two of the DPS players because I was like Because I was either like I picked two supports two DPS two supports one DPS or one tank or Two tanks one DPS and one support Alright,
or I mean sorry two tanks or one DPS or like one two supports one deep one DPS and one tank I decided to do two DPS one tank and and me so I was like You guys got kill everything before they kill us DPS I was like you have to kill everything because if you don't My support partner and I will get heavily targeted because of it
So I went in with the killed faster strap
Because I was like, it doesn't matter if we have good support, because if we have good supports, but our DPS doesn't pick up the slack, it wouldn't matter.
Like, we're just making the fights longer.
Anyway, so, we can only have four... we can only have four... one above all... like, above Diamond players.
So, obviously, like, Diamond or above.
So, obviously, I picked three... like, including me, I'm included in that maximum.
I would pick three players who are the highest rank possible.
Because, like, why would I pick a Diamond player, when I could pick, like, an actual, like, pro player?
Anyway, and our fifth player from your suggestions chat... this was actually suggested in the member stream, so you guys gotta congratulate the member goons for suggesting them.
Is that our fifth player is gonna be Kony.
Who's gonna be our other tank player.
So, Kony's joining us, because he's plat, apparently.
I thank fucking God.
And I was, like, asking Kony, I was like, what rank are you?
And he's like, I got to plat, but I stopped playing, because, like, I didn't care.
I just wanted the rewards.
I was like, thank fucking God you stopped playing, Kony.
You're my... you're my scam pointer right there.
You're my actual smurf right there, thank fucking God.
So, Kony was, like, super excited, because he was like, I'm gonna grind all week for the... I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna grind all week, and then he's gonna get additional coaching from Hogs.
So, like, Hogs is gonna, like, the other tank is gonna coach him, and, like, improve the synergy with each other, so they can, like, work together for the tournament.
Because it's gonna be a two-day tournament, guys.
The Twitch Rivals is gonna be, like, two days.
So, um, so, like, we... I just really want to do well.
Like, I just... I just really want... I want to beat Shroud.
That's... I don't think I'm gonna beat him.
I want to meet him at the finals.
That's all I want.
I want to... I want to meet him in the finals, guys.
I don't think I'm gonna beat Shroud.
I just want to... I just want to see him there.
Beat two of Shroud versus... He doesn't even know my existence.
He's like, who is this... who is this streamer that's trying to start beef with me?
Who is this, like, um... who is this, like, not, like, um... um... not important, irrelevant streamer that's trying to start shit right now?
Anyway, so that's basically the gist of everything.
Um, uh, uh, so, uh, that's gonna be... that's basically it.
The tournament's gonna be on the 18th.
Uh, I'm still trying to find one more support player.
Um, and then our team's gonna be full.
Like, we finalized the entire team.
So, I need to find one more support player that's plat and under, but it's very difficult because if that support... I would get really mad if this support tilts me.
Because, like, nothing makes me more mad than a bad support player.
Because, like, I'm like... I actually get really mad.
Because I'm like... I'd be like, why?
Just why?
So, um, I'll be like, I wish I could just clone myself so I don't have to deal with it.
Alright, anyway.
So, yeah.
So, it's gonna be really tough trying to find the sixth player.
Um, I'm... I'd rather... because, like, it's worse for me when I see a bad support player because I'm a support player.
So, I know what they're doing is, like, so wrong if they do something wrong.
And I know, like, it's such an easy fix to me.
And also, guys, I'm gonna... I'm trying to find people that are in NA because of ping.
Um, the ping... uh, the ping diff in, like, Marble Rivals actually hurts so much.
Like, you guys saw me play with 200 ping.
It was... yeah.
So, I'm gonna... I'm trying to find people in NA.
You really need a good ping for it.
Uh, but anyway.
That's the Marble Rivals update.
I already told the members these.
So, but yeah.
Um, you guys gotta thank the member goons.
Uh, for suggesting, uh, Kony to be part of the team because he was super down for it and was, like, really excited.
Like, he was, like, oh my god, like, now that I have a goal, I'm gonna hard grind Marble Rivals.
Um, and, like, see how far we're gonna get.
Because, yeah, so that makes me super excited because I think Kony has a lot of potential to be, like, really, really good at the game.
And he's also, like, super vibey and, like, really funny too.
So, I'm very excited, uh, for the team in general.
And the pro players I picked up to be part of my team is also, like, because I played with them.
And they're, like, incredibly, like, you know, they're really funny people.
So, I'm very excited.
Um, anyway.
God of War!
I need to plug in my controller.
Oh, no, where's the controller?
Oh, guys, I talk too much.
I don't know how I did it.
I didn't prepare the most important thing.
Where's my controller?
There you see.
I used a PlayStation controller, right?
Is that it?
Where is it?
Where did I put the controller?
Did I use a PlayStation controller?
Or was it...
Or was it an Xbox controller?
Because there's an Xbox controller here.
But where's my PlayStation controller?
Oh, no, guys.
Any Vine viewers?
Um, it's been so long.
Wait, where is my PlayStation controller?
Where the fuck is it?
Oh, my God.
Guys, this is not good.
I actually don't know where my PlayStation controller went.
It can't be far.
There's no way.
It can't be far because where would I put it?
Does she know?
Oh, my God.
Wait, guys, I need to...
Guys, we have a problem.
I don't know.
Where's my PlayStation controller?
Oh, my God.
I literally...
We have everything fucked all over there.
Oh, my God.
Where is it?
What?
Where could I put it?
Was it PlayStation or was it Xbox?
I don't remember.
I need you guys to remind me.
My brain has not...
I don't remember previous streams sometimes.
Like, I do remember, but, like, not which controller I used.
It was PlayStation?
Yeah.
How the fuck did I put my PlayStation controller?
Okay, that's not it.
Oh, my God.
The one issue we have.
It was almost perfect.
But we were just missing the PlayStation controller.
Oh, it's over here.
Why did I put it back here?
All right.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I found it.
I found it.
Oh, my God.
It's okay, guys.
I found it, everyone.
DarkBlade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so happy I suggested Kony.
I love you, too, and your collab so much.
Thank you for the super chat, DarkBlade.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah.
Thank you guys for telling me he was a plat tank player.
I legitimately thought tank would be the hardest to find.
Because, like...
Getting a good tank is, like, really difficult.
Because, like, they're so rare.
But, like, getting a support player is a lot easier than finding a tank player.
Like, a low-rank tank player.
So, thanks, guys.
All right, I need to restart the game, because...
It doesn't recognize the controller right now.
Yay!
All right, restarting my game.
Um...
New, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Such a shame you don't find your controller.
I guess we need to switch to Marvel Rivals.
Guys, life is not just about Marvel Rivals.
I swear to God, guys.
There's more to life than just Marvel Rivals.
Guys, I swear there's more to life than just Marvel Rivals.
I swear to God.
Guys...
I swear...
I'm more than just Marvel Rivals.
Okay, continue.
Um...
Where was I?
Has to be this one.
This is the most recent.
All right.
Here we go.
This is it.
All right.
I don't rem...
Where did I leave off?
I do remember, but I also don't remember at the same time.
Oh, do I have...
Oh, I have new stuff!
Oh my God, I need to upgrade my stuff.
I feel so weak inside right now.
Okay, a momentum from...
Uh...
Defense.
No, that's fine.
And then, does my son have better clothes?
No, he does not.
That's okay.
That's...
That's okay, son.
You don't need better clothes.
All right, we gotta upgrade our...
We gotta upgrade our son.
All right, son.
I'm going all in on you.
All right, son?
You're gonna get everything in the world.
All right, nice.
I don't know what I'm upgrading.
I know...
I'm pretty sure you guys are yelling at me about the upgrades, but like, that's okay.
All right.
I invested so much money on my son.
He better repay me.
And then when I get old, he will fucking take care of me when I'm older.
Right, son?
You won't fuck this up, right?
No, I just fixed the audio.
Don't worry.
He's not gonna fuck this up.
He knows.
He knows I paid for your college.
You're gonna pay me back, right, boy?
Right?
Okay, let's grab this.
All right, boy.
Where do I go, boy?
Oh wait, I should like...
See if I can spend some money.
Take care of me when I grow up, boy.
What?
Oh shit, sorry.
I had to tab out real quick.
What?
What are you gonna make?
Oh!
I could make better weapons.
All right.
My bow can be upgraded.
Okay.
Okay, talent bow.
All right, boy!
It's time!
You're going to university whether you like it or not, boy.
So you can get a good job and take care of me when I'm older.
That's fucking right.
All right, and then I'll upgrade your quiver.
Got your quiver upgrade.
And I'll make sure you go to college.
I will make sure.
I don't know if I should upgrade armor.
I feel like it's such a waste in general upgrading my armor.
Because I always feel like I'm going to find better armor later.
Boy, you will become a doctor and lawyer.
I swear to God.
Do you want me to remind you how much money I have spent on you, boy?
Do you?
Do you remember, boy?
What is the point of knowing how to read or write if you're not going to become a fucking doctor?
All right.
Here we go.
Yes.
Where do I go?
Is it here?
Where the fuck do I go?
Where did I come from?
Oh, here.
Wait, no, I remember I climbed up here.
But...
Okay, it's this way.
Is it this way?
It's yellow.
But it's yellow.
Is this not it?
Kudo, right?
Can't jump down.
Oh, fucking... Okay, sorry.
There we go.
Wait, how do I...
How do I grab it back?
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, boy.
Boy, sorry.
I'm like...
I need to remember how to play this game.
How do I grab it back?
Oh, there it goes.
It's triangle.
Do I need to do another one?
Is this not done yet?
Boy, did you do it, boy?
Boy?
What did I do?
What did I...
Boy, what did I... Boy, explain.
Oh, it's over there.
Thanks, boy.
Thanks, boy, for explaining.
Your old man appreciates it.
See, that's...
See, and this is exactly why... Oh my god.
Alright, boy.
That's right.
Good job, boy!
Good job!
That's right.
That's what my millions of dollars of investment was worth... was for.
Okay, now how do I get over there?
Alright, circle.
There we go.
Good job.
Circle.
Yes, boy.
I learned how to jump.
Yup.
Circle time!
Good shooting.
Oh, that looks like a bad person.
That's right.
Watch this, boy!
I'm a little concerned that he's not taking damage, my boy.
Why is he slowly walking up to me?
Why is he...
Boy?
Boy!
Boy, I'm... Oh, shit!
Boy.
I don't feel so good, boy.
I...
I don't feel so good.
It's okay.
I got this.
And I got this.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Okay, nevermind.
Okay, but like, that was pretty sick, though.
Was that not?
With the ability?
Oh my god, please.
Learn how to aim.
I really...
I really need you to learn how to aim.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Oh, oh, it's alright.
That's alright.
That's not okay.
That's...
Oh my god!
Bro!
This is a 1v1!
The boy is just an accessory, so it doesn't count.
Okay.
Oh!
There you go.
That's fine.
Swing!
No, I'm not!
Please!
He's one!
Boy, please!
Just shoot him one time!
Oh, not even hard.
Not even close, guys.
Not even fucking close.
So easy.
Flawless victory.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I was like...
You saw that red HP?
It was like red...
It was not actually red HP.
It was like my second bar.
Is that it?
Oh!
I could have pushed this here.
Oh, hey.
There's a HP thing over there.
Okay.
Nice.
Wait, can I climb up this?
If I move that?
I feel like I could move this somewhere.
Right?
Okay, I'm just pushing it back.
I don't know.
I feel like I could move this somewhere.
But where do I move?
Oh!
It was all the way behind me.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
I don't need no help.
I'm a gamer.
Alright,
nice.
I got a hack silver, whatever that is.
Oh wait, no.
I got money.
And I got HP.
And...
Yeah, go this way.
I'm not tired.
I'm at my second win.
Rip me, boy.
Or you will fall to your death.
I think we go down, right?
Okay, yeah, we do.
And then...
Okay, we go right side.
And...
Where else do we have to go?
Up?
Up.
Uh...
Left?
No?
Oh, right.
I see the yellow paint, guys.
I see the vision.
What happens?
Yeah, what now?
Can I do it?
Wait, what?
Oh!
Alright, shoot it!
Nice.
Simple geometry.
What do you mean, what?
Did I not do it?
Alright, do it again, boy!
Do it again!
Oh, that's right!
Simple geometry and physics.
I almost failed math.
But that's what my boy investment is for.
Alright.
Oh, there's another one.
Right here.
Uh...
I wonder what happens if I shoot it now.
What are you doing?
What?
Shoot!
Oh my god, shoot!
Boy!
Boy, it's right- Oh my god, do I have to push you?
Do I have to push you?
Boy!
Why aren't you shoot- Okay.
Oh my god, boy, please.
Why aren't you shooting?
Can I not back up?
I just go up?
Oh, I just go up.
Okay.
That's right, I definitely knew it too, boy.
That's fucking right.
I knew exactly what to do.
Boy.
I didn't work.
9 to 5.
Every day.
So you can ask stupid questions.
Anyway, let's go.
That's it, that's all I'm gonna say.
Alright, let's see.
Up...
Then...
Wait, what's that sound?
What was that?
Right, thank you for the very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay,
I just...
Sorry, okay.
I should've read that in my head.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
XBread, thank you for the super chat.
Well,
I don't think like this one yet.
Because he still took care of the boy.
He still took care of him.
It's just tough love, you know?
He's like one of those dads who are like...
You must never show emotion, boy.
Or you're fucking weak.
Do not cry, boy.
Keep your emotions inside.
You know, that type of dad.
I will let no boy of mine practice magic.
Alright, cool.
That type, yeah.
But he's still there.
He's still there.
He just doesn't know how to raise a child properly.
Because I'm pretty sure...
It's like a cycle where...
Strength, Runic Defense.
Where it's basically like...
His dad raised him like this.
So he's gonna raise him like it too.
Because look at him.
Now he's a man!
Now look at me, freedom nipple.
And thus you shall become just like me.
My dad was raised like this.
And his father's father was raised like this.
And you shall be raised like this too, boy.
And that's why you shall not be using magic like a fucking...
I'm trying to think of what's like pathetic.
Like...
HAHAHAHA That's why you shall not be raised with magic, boy.
You're not gonna be like those weak boys out there.
Who practices ballet.
That's like...
That's like Kratos singing.
That's not what like I think, guys.
Like a...
Like an elf, you're right.
Like a fucking elf.
Are you an elf, boy?
Or are you a man?
Sure.
I'm roleplaying, guys.
It's not actually how I feel, guys.
I just need you guys.
This is all roleplay, guys.
This is all roleplay.
I need you to know that.
Crawl through this hole.
Guys, I need you to know this is all roleplay.
What does it say?
When time itself is deserted, the
forms...
Those symbols?
The seasons?
Yeah, but the order's all jumbled.
It's gonna be winter, spring, summer, autumn?
Why is there two winter?
It's from a song Mother used to sing.
Do I know that one?
Winter like...
Quiet head.
Doesn't like music either.
Got it.
What?
Oh!
Okay, winter.
Spring.
Summer.
Autumn!
Okay, that's not autumn.
There you go.
Sing the song!
Do it, boy!
Sing me a song right now!
Your mother's dead!
What?
Winter, spring, summer, autumn.
Oh, fuck!
I had to do it backwards.
Okay, I figured it out.
Winter.
Spring.
Oh, wait.
Sorry, Jake.
I pressed...
Okay, sorry.
I actually pressed square.
Alright, summer.
Summer.
I like how you guys like, preemptively said, well done.
Like...
You're like, well done, Doki!
As I got it wrong again.
There we go.
Now you guys can say good job.
Good job, Doki.
Solo.
It means endure.
Try it.
Solo.
Oh my god, there's an earthquake.
What's going on?
Whoa!
Oh my god, we did it!
I did it.
Move aside, boy.
I did this.
I paid for his education, so I get to take credit for it.
Keep writing.
Solo.
Right, boy!
Right!
I spent a million dollars on this private school education.
Now, fucking right!
Yeah.
Oh, that sounds bad.
Oh, it's like an elevator.
Am I gonna get, like, granite?
Oh, I'm gonna get ran at.
That's alright.
Oh shit, wait!
Oh!
He's still figh- Oh wait, he's gonna fight with me?
Go back and right, I can handle this!
Boy!
Right!
I don't need your bull!
Go away- Oh wait, he's dead.
Okay, cool.
Really?
He's behind?
Oh yeah, he is.
Okay, that's fine.
Send in the wolves!
Send in the fucking wolves!
Oh, he's gone.
Oh, I can- I can, like, uh...
Oh, I can, like, do pushback!
I didn't know that.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
Now read.
Back to writing!
Boy!
I didn't need your help!
Alright.
Right, boy, now write!
Write for me!
He's just writing one word.
I could've just done this myself.
Like, I didn't even have to know what the fuck I'm writing.
I could've- I could've just wrote this myself!
Alright, come on.
Get him out of here.
Oh!
That's fucking right!
Just cause you're big doesn't mean you're strong!
Unless you're me.
Oh no.
You touch me?
You dare to touch me?
How dare you!
No touchy!
That's fucking right!
You don't get to touch me!
Only I get to touch this beautiful body!
No touchy!
Oh shit!
Oh no!
Okay, write again!
Oh, we're not done yet, apparently!
We're not done yet!
Alright.
The only maiden that was allowed to touch this is dead.
So nobody else can touch this beautiful, sculpted body.
Sculpted by the hands of God.
So only I am worthy to touch myself.
Honestly, like, these guys are so weak, so- Oh.
Honestly, these guys are so- I still think they're really weak!
Doesn't matter!
Like, yeah, they're weak as hell.
Oh, alright, now we actually fight.
Now we fucking fight.
Where's the other guy?
Get over here.
Get over here!
Oh, you fucking touch this, you die!
You fucking die!
Alright- WHAT?!
They can just dodge that?!
That's it, I'm done.
I'm fucking done.
Okay.
I'll get this guy up.
Oh, this is a bit of a waste of a time, but that's okay!
It looked really cool, though!
It looked so cool, though, guys!
You don't understand!
It looked so fucking cool, though!
Where is she?
Where's the witch?
Oh no, this is- Oh my god, it's gonna break!
Please, is that the last one?
Oh no!
Okay, that has to be the last one!
Right!
Right, boy, right!
Okay, nice.
We're okay now.
We're almost there.
Pola!
He's literally writing one word!
I could've done this myself!
Oh shit!
Oh shit, oh no!
I didn't know.
Oh no!
Boy, please!
What do I do?
Jump, jump!
Alright, nice.
We made it.
We fucking made it.
I don't need no shield.
That is for- That's elf talk.
Shields are- This is curly cosmetic.
Shields are for elves and PUSSIES!
And I ain't no pussy!
True.
If you use a shield, you are not a real man.
You might as well cover up your nipples, too.
How dare you show your chest to me?
Wait, what?
Why didn't it let me kill him?
Alright, off I go.
He is not cool.
Alright, push boy!
PUSH!
I feel like he's not actually helping at all.
There's no way that boy can push up a fucking mountain.
I feel like I'm just doing that to let him feel good about himself.
Do not be afraid!
He's like, I was never afraid in the first place, but now I will!
He's totally helping.
Bro, that was a sick shot.
6'3", 360 no scope.
Alright.
Nice, we did it.
We made it!
Yay!
That bird kinda cracked.
The chisel tip!
Give the man credit.
He has a talent for destroying things.
Remember that head.
Never leaves my mind.
Alright, we go...
How do we get- oh, down?
There's like something below me.
How do I get down there?
Wait, I wanna go down there.
Ooh, I might need to go on a diet.
Yeah.
Woah.
Woah, daddy has had too much carbs, boy!
Wait, where's that coming from?
Magni?
Magni and Modi?
Oh, there we go.
Found it.
This is more important, boy.
It's called loot.
Somebody died here and I must take their loot.
Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
Up... and then...
Oh, there it is.
There's the ledge.
Uh... oh.
Hey, guys!
I don't trust these guys.
I don't trust the dead bodies at all.
I feel like there always could be something.
Alright, up I go.
Up!
Oh!
It was those guys!
Oh, there's sons of Thor?
What?
Wait, but...
How the fuck do I get to the other side?
What?
Oh, there.
Okay, it wouldn't let me jump for some reason.
That's so weird.
Jump!
That's right, boy.
Do it again!
Make daddy proud!
Do that jump again, boy!
That's right, get- Oh, okay.
Oh, you want to do the jump?
I'm gonna leave you then.
Come on!
Do that jump!
Oh, you don't want to do the jump now?
Oh my god, I'm so proud of you, boy.
Now jump again!
Stretch those legs!
There we go.
I'm so proud of him.
He did it.
He's getting those fucking legs working.
Okay.
Door open.
Oh!
Seems like a nice place.
Okay.
Shoot?
Oh, am I gonna fight that?
I'm a little worried.
Oh, okay.
No, I'm not.
Wait, what?
What's gonna happen now?
Oh!
Okay, let's go!
Oh, shit!
What?
What do you think I was- Oh!
I wonder what's gonna happen if I do that!
Guys, I don't know!
Guys, I don't know what- It's like, you're like, I wonder what will happen if I do that.
I wonder.
Oh, there's no way something would actually happen, right?
There's no way.
How was I supposed to know?
How was I supposed to know, guys?
I was- I didn't know!
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
Oh, wait.
Maybe my boy can just do it.
Just kill him.
I feel like- Oh, shit!
You know what?
I don't even have to kill him.
Legitimately, I can- Yeah, my boy can just kill him.
He can just solo him.
There you are.
That's fucking right!
Get down!
Nice.
Yeah!
Oh, what's that?
Something's- That tramples the enemy?
Oh.
It stuns.
Oh, but the damage is not that good.
I like the- Oh, no.
I like the wolf more.
I don't need- I feel like- Yeah, I'm gonna keep the wolf.
I like the wolf.
Nice.
I don't know why I- I don't know why I thought- I'd be like, there's no way he's gonna come out.
Come out of that.
No.
There's no way.
What's over on this side, then?
Is it also people?
Oh, it was people.
Wait, so I made it harder for myself.
Accidentally.
You know what?
I don't even need to fight.
I'm just distraction.
Go, boy!
Show me what you got, boy!
Woah!
Show me what you got!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, sorry.
Come on, do your thing, boy!
He's almost dead!
Woah!
Okay, how does that hit?
Okay, that's- that's- oh shit.
Oh shit, I became a- oh no, that's not what I wanted.
No, boy!
You ruined it!
You ruined the run, boy!
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
You ruined the run!
I can't believe you made me use that shield!
Oh man!
I gotta go to the gym after this.
Now dad's angry and he must go to the gym and drink his protein powder.
I gotta increase the testosterone now.
Alright, nice.
Got XP.
I got this.
Nice.
Alright, uh...
Get swole for the boys.
Oh.
Oh, what the fuck?
I didn't- I didn't even do anything!
Okay.
I actually- Okay, do I have enough for him?
You know what?
Fuck it, let me- Let me just- Wait, no.
Let me just swing my axe around.
Oh shit!
Oh no.
Come on.
Oh!
No, I can do it again!
And I can do it again!
Oh shit!
Wait, he has fire claws?!
Wait, that's illegal!
Okay.
I'm gonna swing.
And then...
And then I'm gonna- What?!
Oh my god!
It just went down!
He has rabies!
Jesus Christ.
Guys, you didn't see me use the shield.
I would never do that.
I'm not a fucking elf.
What do you mean you're not ready?
What the fuck do you mean you're not ready?
What do you mean?
Oh nice, I got it.
Nice.
Down.
Oh, that was rough.
That was pretty rough, guys.
Not gonna lie.
But I'm okay now.
Kratos does not give a fuck about rabies.
Alright guys.
If I start being afraid of water, we know what happened.
Alright.
Let's go up here.
And then let's grab this guy's treasure.
And I guess we go this way.
What?
What's ahead?
Wait, how did he get here?
A whetstone?
Whetstone?
What do you mean a whetstone?
Okay.
Can I upgrade my... no, not yet.
I don't know.
I don't wanna buy...
I don't wanna buy like...
I don't wanna buy any armor.
Cause I feel like I'm just gonna find better armor later.
You know?
So I don't really wanna buy any.
Get the revive stone?
Where's the revive stone?
Oh, there he is.
I don't need no revive stone.
What do you think I am?
An elf?
You think I'm a fucking elf, chat?
I don't need no revives.
A man gets it done once and that's all he needs.
Wait, why is this locked?
Do I need to like grab this?
And throw it out here?
And shoot it?
Oh, there it is.
God, I'm so smart.
Famous last words.
I just need one last word.
And try.
Alright, and then...
I can lock this now.
No magic can stop me.
I'll steal your... I'll steal your grave no matter what.
Alright, this way.
And then...
This way.
And then this way.
Oh, why is there lava there?
Oh shit.
You think they noticed?
That's mean.
Oh shit!
Um...
Hey there.
I see you freed your nipple too.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait.
No, wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
I invested in the boy.
I was gonna be like, there's no way.
There's no way you're gonna take the boy away.
I refuse to let you take the boy away from me.
I spent way too much money for this.
You will not take him away.
Oh guys, guys.
Sometimes you have to use...
Sometimes...
Thanks boy.
Oh shit.
Sometimes you have to use it.
Okay, it's...
This is...
Oh shit!
Hey guys.
Guys.
Guys, why are they so strong?
Wait a minute.
Why are they really, really strong?
Oh no.
What?
What's going on?
Doing what?
Oh.
Oh god.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
It's coming so slowly towards me.
Oh my god.
Oh no!
No!
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
Okay.
Keep using your bow boy!
Oh god.
Okay.
Oh shit!
That's fine.
Oh I have to...
No!
Break it!
Oh shit.
I did not mean...
I did not mean to do that!
That's fine.
Just keep using your bow boy!
Okay.
Oh shit!
It's fine!
We're so healthy!
Oh we're so healthy!
Oh fuck!
Where is that going?
I don't know!
Oh fuck!
Okay.
Okay it's fine.
It's fine!
I can't see!
Wait what?
Okay come on!
Come on!
Please!
Oh no!
What?
Woo!
They baited me!
Oh.
Wow!
Oh my god!
I'm so scared!
That's fine!
We got him!
Boy!
Be careful boy!
They're Norse!
No!
Be careful!
What?
Okay nice!
Nice!
Oh my god!
Are you fucking serious?
Come on!
Please!
Wait he has?
Oh shit he has!
I was like what?
Oh shit!
We're not healthy anymore guys!
I'm a little scared!
Come on!
Oh no!
No please!
Oh shit!
Come on!
No I didn't break it!
Oh my god!
This is so scary!
Oh fuck!
There we go!
This is it!
Come on!
He's so low!
Oh no!
No!
Come on!
He's so low!
Boy I'm very scared boy!
Because I'm very, very low!
And I really need you to do something!
Come on!
Please!
Oh no!
Oh!
Attack!
Do it!
That's right I'm gonna cut off your nipples!
You don't deserve nipples!
That's right I did it!
He did not deserve to keep the nipples free!
Huh?
Oh!
I almost restart!
Oh my god I did it!
Oh my god!
I'm so scared!
I thought I got the restart!
Are you okay?
What happened boy?
Why is he sick?
Wait do you have rabies?
Did he bite you?
Oh my god!
That was...
The older son of Thor, he had a huge sword and was really...
And was really mean.
Yeah he was.
He was pretty mean alright.
Alright nice.
Yeah he was a fucking meanie.
Alright, cool.
This man does not deserve to free the nipple.
He was weak!
Only real man can free the nipple.
He should have covered it up like the pussy he is.
Wonder if I can go through here.
He was so rude.
He was a big meanie.
What a meanie head.
True.
Oh!
Swing!
Alright, I got it.
Should do.
Yippee!
Okay, return to the boat.
Oh!
What a coincidence.
Find the binding point and then...
How do I know what the binding point is?
Is it this?
Then?
Oh is it this?
Right?
That?
Oh!
Okay.
I get it.
Yeah!
We killed so many things, boy.
Oh, they'll just make more babies.
Boy, it's okay.
All gods love to do is fuck.
They'll just make new children.
You think he really cares?
That's all they do, boy.
New lesson for you.
How do I ticket this?
It's like...
It's over there.
Oh, okay.
I just throw my...
I just throw it.
Where's the other one, though?
There's one here.
But where's the two and three?
Just another Tuesday for the gods.
Sometimes they don't even fuck each other.
Sometimes they wanna bang an animal.
And apparently, that is morally okay for them.
I'm looking at you, Loki!
You're really, really lucky.
You like the...
You really, really like the animals.
Didn't like...
Didn't like Zeus...
Like...
Didn't he turn into a goose?
At one point?
Oh, he was a freak freak.
Where the fuck are the other seals?
Oh, there it is.
There's one.
He turned into a lot of things.
Oh, hey there.
Hey there, boy.
No, they all...
They all really, really like to turn into animals.
Specifically, animals.
I'm missing one more.
Don't the original furry.
Honestly?
No.
No, you're right.
No, I won't argue against that.
It was the...
The birth father of a furry.
I'm like, missing one more seal and it has to be here.
Oh, I hate seal searching.
I hate it so much.
Oh, he is the fur father.
You are correct.
He truly was one of the greats.
You saw it?
Which way?
I didn't see it.
I feel like you're lying to me.
Boy, please.
I'm trying to find the stupid seal.
Where could it be?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god.
Is this like playing like...
Like those picture...
The find the picture book stuff?
Oh, yeah.
That should open it.
Uh...
I started from one of those...
Like those...
Like...
The hidden pictures.
They're not...
I mean, it's sort of like Where's Waldo?
But the other one.
The other picture book.
The one where like...
Uh...
I Spy!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I felt like I was playing I Spy there.
But not the fun way.
Okay, up I go.
Up.
Down.
Okay, and then...
Oh, wait.
Before I climb up.
I wanna get this out first.
Oh, I backtracked.
Oh my god.
Green is not a creative color.
Okay, nice.
I can finally upgrade my axe.
Yay!
Can I upgrade anything else?
I don't wanna upgrade any...
I don't wanna upgrade all of these.
Uh...
Do I have anything for you?
I don't, right?
Wasn't there another door?
Oh, there's the other door.
No!
I will find better armor.
I don't need to waste my money on fucking armor.
There you go.
He said he's fine, guys.
Guys, I know how to raise my son!
There you go.
What do you realize, boy?
Oh yeah, he did.
Interesting.
Okay,
I'm gonna find...
Oh!
Wait, can I bring it over?
I wonder if I can bring it over.
Boy.
Do not worry.
You are a man.
You shall toughen up and beat the virus up with your fucking fists.
Oh, I can't.
I can't pick that up.
You'll beat up the virus with your fists if you have to.
Wait, how do I...
Okay, there you go.
Oh, I need to get the crystal first.
There you go.
Wait, this is not...
Do I need to...
What?
Where's the red?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, and then we chuck it up here.
And then you explode it.
And then we grab the crystal.
Loli, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Poseidon made the queen of Crete have the hots for a bowl, making the minotaur.
Also, what about Egypt?
Almohad god millennia.
Before the Greeks.
People were just fucking freaky.
Oh.
And then...
I wonder who was the first furry.
Oh, what did I get?
Me.
It was me.
What was the...
What was the first civilization that was like, man, that's pretty hot.
Alright, and then...
Get over here, boy.
Boy, I need you over here to open my chest, boy.
Oh my god, I have to like...
I have to like...
Go here.
So he'll follow me.
And then go over here.
So he'll shoot this.
Boy, please.
Okay.
Now shoot it.
Oh my god, boy, please.
Boy, oh my god, boy.
I can't.
I can't with you.
You gotta beat up that virus faster.
You gotta...
You gotta fix you faster, boy.
His tuberculosis is actually affecting him.
Oh, hey, it is.
Oh, I do this.
Oh.
Swing.
Okay.
Sorry.
Swing.
What do I do here?
Oh, okay.
We climb up.
Go get it, boy.
Make daddy proud.
What is he gonna do?
What is he doing?
Oh!
Is he on it?
I can't tell.
Oh, he is.
He's just so small.
Alright, there we go.
And you know what to do, right?
Come on!
Oh, you want me to tell you to drop the rope?
Oh, thanks for telling me there's a rope and not dropping it, my son.
I love you.
I love you so much.
Huh?
Okay, this way.
Wait, what?
Do I have to jam it?
Huh?
I jam this?
No.
Wait, I can?
I'm thinking.
Oh!
Okay.
Now that he's on the other side.
Wait, there is one?
Where is it?
Did I like look at it and didn't care?
Oh, I did.
I did.
I looked at it and didn't care.
I did it, guys.
Oh, sorry.
I did not mean it.
Sorry, I missed input, guys.
I do not beat up children.
I swear to God, it was a mis-input.
I did not...
I do not beat up children.
Okay, now that we got that out of the way, we can do this.
Oh, what?
What's glowing?
Oh, it's here.
Okay, and then...
Right here.
Hey!
Door open!
Huh?
Are we?
I'm a little lost.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, grab that.
I came from here.
So, it should be up here.
But there's something up here, though.
There's a yellow here.
Is there anything here?
Have I been here before?
Oh, no.
Oh, wait!
I have been here!
Whoa!
Whoops.
My bad.
Got you.
I didn't realize we're backtracking.
Even though the entire thing was that we're backtracking.
I know he told us we're going back, but then I also did not realize we were going back.
Oh, we're back here!
But what is it?
Okay.
I played these games before!
I feel better now.
I told you!
My boy's not a pussy!
He beat up the virus with his own fist!
We don't need...
Wait, there's a door?
Wait, where's the door?
He walked it off.
That's my boy!
He strangled the virus!
Oh, can't use the door right now?
Okay.
We'll go back.
Alright,
let's row our boat back.
Row, row, row your boat, gently down the stream.
Merrily, merrily, merrily...
Okay, I didn't blow my nose.
Go tell your stories.
Oh!
It's the witch!
Alright, we'll go this way.
And then...
Well...
That's the way to go.
Okay, thank God we have the hand to guide us.
Should be this way, right?
Wait, wasn't there a door right here?
I don't remember.
I remember there was a dead guy here.
Did I find her bones yet?
No, there wasn't.
Alright.
I go now.
Goodbye.
Well, I know when I don't need to do that.
Goodbye now.
Alright, I guess he'll never be reunited with his love.
Good fucking riddance.
He needs to learn.
There's no such thing as love.
Oh!
It's all fake.
Wait, what?
Wait, I saw something.
It was invisible.
I saw it.
But it was invisible.
What?
Is it here?
Do I dock it here?
Oh, I do.
Oh, there's a mystery door!
Mystery door.
I like how the head has it's own little seat too.
Right here.
Here's one of them.
And then here's the second.
Oh, there's a third?!
Is there treasure?
What's in here?
Another one of these.
Oh, Reed, boy.
The middle panel is missing.
Oh.
I thought Tyr was a rock, not a giant.
Ah, but he was loved by everyone, including the Giants.
Other than me, he was the only one they gifted with their special sight.
Hey, I wonder if the Giants left a triptych about me somewhere too.
Oh.
Sorry, I just need to adjust the volume.
Cause every time I mute, the volume goes down!
Alright.
Oh, he can't finish reading.
What do I do?
But where?
Boy, if I haven't learned how to read by now...
I'm not here to learn to read now.
Boy.
Boy, I...
I am...
I have to be really, really old right now, boy.
And I'm not here to...
I am not here to actually learn.
It is a choice, boy.
It was not...
It was a choice.
Ha ha!
Boy, I am not stupid.
I know how to read.
What?
What do I smell?
What is that?
What?
Whoa!
Oh shit!
Ha ha ha!
Let me touch the electricity!
Oh my god!
Boy, I am...
Yeah, he definitely got that from me.
We gotta kill him before he resists!
Ha ha ha!
What?
Oh shit!
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Ha ha ha!
Alright, boy.
You did your best, boy!
You...
You did your best.
I...
It's the effort.
He died.
He...
He Spartan Rage failed.
He failed the quick time event, guys.
This isn't over!
You see how he covered up his nipples now?
Cause you know he doesn't deserve it.
You have to get him to Freya quickly.
There's no other way.
No.
He was supposed to beat up the virus.
No!
You were supposed to be strong, not overload!
Like, what the fuck, boy?
What?
This way?
Boy, that was so sad.
That he didn't walk it off.
That was so...
That was pretty funny.
It felt like he was like...
You know when you had to...
You put too many, um...
Chargers on the outlet?
You know that?
And then it just...
He just blew up?
That's what it felt like.
It felt like he put...
It felt like he actually overloaded the circuits.
Boy, you were supposed to walk it off.
You were supposed to beat up the virus with your hands.
Okay, it is here.
Yeah, he tripped the circuit breaker.
Is it this way?
It has to be this way.
He'll be okay, guys.
Guys, he might be very white right now.
And he might not be breathing.
But he'll be okay, guys.
He'll be so healthy.
He's so fucking healthy.
I swear he's breathing.
Wait, is he a god?
I mean, Freya's a god, so like...
So I guess like...
So he's like tapping into his like...
Potential.
Wait, what the fuck?
It didn't let me dock.
Yeah, he is my son.
I don't know!
It's like how like, you know when people say like...
They can be born non-magical.
I just thought he was born not a god.
Like the 0.1%.
Yeah, but like, you know how there's like a 0.1% that he becomes a failure?
Where he...
I'm sorry, I mean...
You know, when he's born with nothing.
So I just thought that he was born without...
Well, we hit the...
We hit the lottery, but like the bad lottery.
Poor boy.
Yeah, you know like, it skipped a generation, you know?
I was like...
We hit the lottery, but like...
The bad kind of lottery.
Oh my god, I knew you had some god in you.
I knew it.
Don't worry, boy.
Now that I know you're an actual god...
Now I love you.
Now I will finally acknowledge you, boy.
Alright, here we go.
Freya!
We need your help!
Woman, do you hear me?!
It is urgent!
I'm still a god!
Go away!
What the fuck?!
Inside.
This is no ordinary illness.
The boy's true nature, your true nature, fights within him.
I
did this to him.
Will you help me?
Oh, you look so sad.
Of course.
There is a rare ingredient found only in Helheim.
The keeper that protects the Bridge of the Damned.
I need its heart.
Hell?
The Realm of the Dead.
Do you know it?
Not this one.
It is a land of unyielding gold.
Fires cannot burn there and no magic in all the Nine Realms can create a blaze.
As for the dead, your Frost Axe will be useless.
You'll need to find something else.
I need the Fire Axe.
Oh my god, I gotta kill Hela before she revives the son.
Dig up her past, I swore.
It would stay buried.
Who you were before doesn't matter.
This boy is not your past, he is your son.
And he needs his father.
Hela needs...
Oh?
Wait, isn't there one bridge?
Who's gonna take care of the bridge after he's dead?
Would that mean like the undead can go in and out whenever they want now?
Not his problem.
It's not our problem.
I will keep him safe.
That's a mother's promise.
Alright.
Oh no.
Wait.
I invested so much money into him.
Wait a minute.
I have to do my own work?
Oh no.
Now I actually have to do my own work.
Now I have to kill people myself?
My boat is down the path.
Go.
Helheim of all places.
Oh my god.
There it is.
I will do what I must.
I wasted so much money on this boy.
No!
Oh shoot.
Now what?
This boat...
This boat is not... not it for him.
Spooky.
This boat is not manly.
Oh.
Maybe Thor found out his son is dead.
Hello?
What the fuck?
Who are you?
She's creepy.
Athena?
Oh my god.
Woman.
I don't like that.
What?
Oh.
Okay.
I asked politely and it happened.
That's all it needs.
Get out of my head.
What?
Who is she?
Creepy.
Why is she living rent free in my head?
Oh.
Thor is angry.
Angry.
Sorry guys.
I forgot to take my meds.
Sometimes I see women pop up when that happens.
Hello?
See?
You too.
Alright.
What's going on?
Am I at Hella yet?
Is this Helheim?
Oh.
End of the road.
It's the end of the road.
Oh.
Oh, this song is really spooky.
I'm not feeling well.
Oh my god.
No.
Wait.
I forgot.
Wait a minute.
Oh fuck.
Am I allowed to kill him?
Oh.
Is it heads?
I don't remember.
How do I sheath my...
How do I sheath it?
Oh my god.
Guys, give me a sec.
Okay, now.
Okay, now I remember.
Guys, it's been so long.
I don't remember.
It's okay.
Now I do.
Get over here.
That's alright.
I got it.
Get out!
That's right.
Like, why would I ever need to use my hands until now?
It's been so long since I used my fists.
It's been so fucking long.
I don't need my axe to kill you.
Catch these hands.
That's right.
Oh, you thought you could just come out of the ground like that?
You really thought so?
Oh shit.
Whoops.
Give me a sec.
Let me... Okay, give me a sec.
Okay, there you go.
Now, round two!
Round two!
That's right.
Get over here.
You saw what I did?
Now it's your turn.
Now it's your turn too.
It's fine.
That's fine.
That's good.
Get out!
I'll suplex you!
Okay, last guy.
That's right.
Save the best for last.
Can you heal myself?
That's not heals.
And that should be my heals.
Is there anything here?
Oh, there is.
Okay, I got an artifact.
Is there anything else here?
Hello?
Can't survive without child labor.
Historically accurate.
I'm just... I was so used to living the good life, guys.
And now I have to fight for myself?
Thank you for the super chat, John.
Thank you.
Okay, door open.
Hello?
What's in it?
Those are the original blades from the games!
God, it looks dull as fuck.
Oh, my hands are shaking.
Oh no, I'm going through withdrawals right now.
Oh, the Blade of Chaos!
Teacher.
Husband.
Father.
But there is one unavoidable truth you will never escape.
You cannot change.
You will always be...
A good father?
A monster.
I know.
I thought I was doing a good job.
But I am no longer a monster.
Oh, it's time.
It's fucking time!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Holy shit, why the fuck did I run away from my path?
I look so cool!
He said the thing.
Oh, my God.
I thought I was doing really well raising my boy.
But I legitimately thought...
Holy shit!
And I was using a fucking axe?
When I could have just done this?
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
I legitimately could have done so much more if I just got this out sooner.
Let the chaos roam.
That's fucking right.
I'm so fucking strong.
If I'm gonna be the monster, I'm gonna be the best monster in this... in this world.
That's fucking right.
You guys are nothing!
Oh, my God.
The range is actually crazy, though.
I could have killed so many people so much faster.
Like, who cares about trauma?
If I kill everything, then, like, I can't feel bad about stuff anymore.
I'll just get Descent's Ties.
Wait.
Wait, Doki.
Was it not here?
Where's the shortcut?
Oh, it's here.
It's here.
Okay.
Holy shit!
Those blades are so strong.
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh, did I forgot to unlock this?
Oh, that's silly of me.
Am I supposed to go back to the shop?
Okay.
I knew you were Greek all along.
Why do they say it like it's a bad thing?
Why do they say it like it's bad that I'm Greek?
What are those?
Don't worry about it.
I look like I'm always gonna cry at any moment.
It was my sperm.
I'm sorry.
Doki.
His son is dying, Doki.
Alright, we gotta upgrade our... Can I upgrade my Blades of Chaos?
I can't even upgrade my Blades of... What's the point?
What the fuck is the point?
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Can I... Do I have skills that I can upgrade?
Where's my Blades of Chaos?
Oh, there we go.
Alright, let's just get everything.
Fuck it.
Get that.
And then, I'm not good enough for the rest, so we'll just... We'll just not worry about that for now.
Defense.
Let's get all the stronger ones.
And then... Oh no, my nipples.
No.
No, I covered my nipples.
Now I'm weak.
I'm so weak now.
My power.
What do I do?
I covered up my power.
How do I free the nipple if it's covered up?
Where is it?
Okay.
Nephilim.
Asgard.
Where's Hela?
Oh, Helam.
There we go.
Helam.
Yay!
How do I get there?
We're gonna get Hela unleashed.
Wait, why do I still have my axe?
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
I did it.
How do I get across?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Alright, time to open the door.
Hello!
Hey guys!
Where's the welcome party?
I'm Greek.
Yeah, but I'm not Norse.
I'm Greek, which is a lot warmer place, but like...
But like, it's alright.
What are you gonna do, huh?
What you gonna do?
I'm not even... Just fucking... Yeah, that's right.
Guys, I'm only... Guys, I'm doing... I'm letting them have like the first hit, okay?
Okay, guys!
Chill out!
Alright.
Easy.
Oh, this range is insane.
Like, who cares about trauma, Kratos?
You're fucking more badass with this.
Guys, I was just letting them get their first hit, okay, guys?
I just want them to feel better about themselves.
Damn, they gave us super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Xcalibur, they gave us super chat!
Okay, there we go.
Let's make sure... Come on!
Burn, baby, burn!
Let's go!
Get out of here!
It's alright.
You're already in hell, so you might as well... You'll come back, right?
Oh hey, nice!
A chest.
Yay!
Wait, is there another chest behind me?
Did I miss it?
There's no other chest, you liars!
There's this!
There was?
Is there really another chest?
How did I miss it?
Oh wait, but I got this.
I didn't see this, though.
Nice, I found the heirloom.
Okay, but I need more money here.
And is there anything here?
Wait, there's a downstairs!
What's downstairs?
Oh, I can't open that yet.
Alright, where is this chest that I missed?
Where is it?
Oh no.
They said I'm really blind, so now I'm...
Oh, it's right here.
Okay, I may or may not be blind.
Oh wait!
Hold L1 and R1 together.
L1 and R1.
Oh shit!
Wait, that's so cool!
Okay.
That's one of my other attacks.
And that's a cool attack.
Alright.
I can't do the attack, apparently.
Apparently, I can't do the- Oh shit, get away, get away!
Oh my god, oh my god, it's the jockey.
It's the fucking jockey from Left 4 Dead 2.
Get whipped.
That's right.
Go to your master!
Oh shit, oh shit!
That's right.
Go there!
Go to hell!
Oh shit.
Hell is overwhelmed?
Oh my god, there's an overpopulation.
I can't believe there's a- There's an overpopulation of hell right now.
We gotta call hell.
Guys, sorry, we have too many people.
We have to take applications now.
Guys, there's a waitlist.
Hell is in demand.
Sorry guys, we have a waitlist.
Please fill out the application.
Okay, we need to go this way.
How can hell be overpopulated?
It should be like unlimited.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, there's just more enemies.
I killed too much.
Honestly, yeah, maybe that's it.
I killed too many people, so now they have an overpopulation problem.
Oh my god, you fucking suck.
God, I hate you.
You can't shield forever.
There's no way you can shield forever.
There's no way.
Ah, that's it.
Oh my god, my chain still hits your shield?
Oh, I hate you.
Oh, I hate both of you.
Okay, I can't shield bash this.
What?
What do I do?
There we go.
I gotta bring an axe to this.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Sorry, I don't know if you guys noticed this, but I don't use the shield at all.
Like, what do I do when they also bring a shield to a fight?
Those fucking pussies.
Aww, this way.
Can't go this way.
Alright, down I go.
Wait, there's a chest here.
Where do I get this chest?
Hold L2 and aim.
Wait, I could've done this the entire time?
Wait.
Okay, this will work.
Alright.
Oh my god, wait, that's so cool!
Wait a minute!
Wait, that's such a cool attack!
Oh my god!
Wait, that's so cool.
I like this attack a lot.
Get over here.
Okay.
That is so OP!
Nice.
Okay.
Wait, I like this weapon.
I like the blades so much more than the axe.
Why did I ever swap?
Who cares about trauma?
I look cool.
Wait, that's not...
Wait, that wasn't supposed to...
Wait a minute.
That wasn't supposed to happen.
Wait a...
Wait a minute!
I thought I could hook you!
Excuse me, you were supposed to get hooked, buddy.
You know what, fuck this.
I'm fucking angry now.
Can't be bothered.
Get over here.
I'm gonna be angry.
Let's hope there's no boss fight where I need to use this power up.
Wait.
Wait, what?
Oop!
So being killed by a Greek?
No, my son!
It's dishonorable to grow old?
Wait, that's fucked.
How dare you live a good life and grow old?
How fucking dare you?
Alright, let's see.
I don't know where to go, cause like...
There's something over here too.
I hope I'm going the right...
I hope I'm going the side quest way.
Okay, this is not it.
Yeah, but I wanna go to areas where I can get loot.
Oh wait, this is where I came from!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Sorry.
I'm a little special.
Look, I'm Greek, guys.
It's fine.
I can make these mistakes.
I was like, what?
If I die of old age and live a happy and prosperous life...
I... I fucked up.
I go to hell.
How dare you?
You fucked up, Doki.
You're not supposed to be happy.
Rip everyone 30 and over.
Thank you for the super chat.
Darkblade, thank you, thank you.
I wanna get like the tree.
Where's the tree?
Wait, I can bring boy back here?
I can bring boy to hell?
That's right, boy, you fucked up.
Who's that?
Oh, that's the keeper?
I am not truly dead.
Doesn't that make you angry?
He's like, alive!
Not dead!
I am mad.
You are not dead.
I am so mad.
What the fuck?
Okay, this is fucked up.
Not gonna lie.
Where is he?
What the fuck?
Okay, I need to...
Okay, this is a little...
This is pretty bad.
This is actually pretty bad.
This is pretty...
This might be pretty bad.
Not gonna lie.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Oh god, okay.
Oh, okay, we're done.
Oh god.
What?
Oh my god.
Please!
This fucker is a pussy!
Are you serious?
Okay.
Oh, I need...
I need heals.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, you can't disappear forever!
Disappear!
Oh shit!
Okay, maybe he can.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
That's right!
You can't disappear forever!
Disappear!
Are you serious?
Wait, that's stupid.
That's actually so dumb.
Oh!
Okay, we're fine.
We're so fine.
Nice.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
Are you serious?!
Oh my god.
Okay, we gotta find heals.
Please!
No!
Oh, there's heals right here.
Oh, that's not a lot of heals.
Are you serious?
Oh no.
Oh!
No!
Okay.
I don't...
Every time he does that, like, I...
I can't predict it properly.
Okay.
Oh god.
Where is he?
Oh, where is he?
Where is he?!
Oh my god, you're such a whore!
You're a pussy!
Fight me like a man!
You're actually such a pussy!
Using magic?!
Oh, fuck you.
Help.
No!
Where is he?
Come on!
He's one-handed, he's one-handed, he's one-handed, he's one-handed!
I'm gonna be greedy!
I'm gonna be... Oh, I can't be greedy.
Are you serious?!
You're such a...
I'm so...
Get over here, get over here, get over here!
Magic cringe!
You're so cringe for using magic!
That's right.
First try.
I'm angry.
I'm so angry.
Give me your heart.
It's not my problem what happens to Helen now.
This is the real greatest.
The bridge will be fine, guys.
I know they have an overpopulation problem, but it'll be fine.
There we go.
For my son.
For my son!
It'll sort itself naturally.
Someone... It's like, you know, like...
Someone will always take over in the end.
It's like a power... What is it?
Like...
There's a word for it.
When someone important dies, another person will take over.
Yeah, I'm sure there's a deputy bridge troll.
Yeah, power vacuum.
It's alright.
It has to be a...
Who's that?
Watching me do all that?
No witnesses.
I have the heart.
I need nothing more.
You're set.
Time not to linger here, though, eh?
You think she saw?
Kratos.
Helium Zeus.
My father.
Your father was Zeus?
Well, that explains a lot.
What is that place?
Never go there.
Understand?
Oh, it's the place where she told me not to cross the bridge.
How is he here?
That is not possible.
It's just an illusion.
Hell's known for torturing its inhabitants with their own past.
We should focus on getting back to your son.
Okay, but like...
But like...
I have generational trauma.
Wait, why am I still using this?
Alright, nice.
Let's see.
Let's grab some heals first.
Real quick.
Let's grab some heals before we do anything.
What does this do?
There's like this...
Oh, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm gonna beat up my dad right now.
Give me a sec, guys.
Oh, I can't.
Wait, what the fuck?
They baited me.
How am I gonna relive my trauma if I can't even go there?
I can't even cross...
Why did they tease me with a good time?
Wow.
Fun fact, boy's daughter is canonically the ruler of hell.
Thank you for the super chat, Patrick.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, what?
Oh, he's gonna upgrade it.
Uh, Giga, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Greedus doesn't have the death pass.
Therefore, they're angry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Arcturus, thank you for the super chat.
I asked why he's angry, but you wouldn't know who I'm referring to.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I can do this now.
Oh.
Reverent and stable can only be held for 10 seconds.
Oh!
What?
The transfer?
Huh?
Hold L2?
But like, where am I transferring it to?
What?
What door?
Oh!
Sorry.
Sorry, I didn't see the other ball.
Sorry, I didn't see the ball in front of me.
Okay, I realize now.
Guys, I'm so smart.
I figured it out.
Don't worry, guys!
Now you can come in the hell!
It's a free country!
Who cares about overpopulation?
Welcome to hell!
Anybody is welcome!
I have opened the borders for all of you!
Surely nothing bad will happen if I do that.
Right, guys?
Surely I'm not going to cause more issues now.
Alright.
Uh...
Is there anything up here?
I wonder if like...
Just like my blades can't bring my boy back here.
What could go wrong?
Exactly, nothing could go wrong.
Uh...
Wait, there's like stuff here.
Okay, let's transfer this over.
Oh shit, I used the wrong... whoops!
Yeah, fuck that place in particular.
Okay, get the wind here.
And then wind over here.
Okay, I just need to make sure...
I need to make sure I kill all these guys first.
That's fucking right.
BEGONE!
I killed... oh shit, okay.
I killed your boss, you think I'm afraid of you?
You know what?
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Oh shit.
Get over here, I killed your boss.
Now you're not gonna get paid.
Alright, nice.
Uh...
Okay, I need the heals.
And then...
Wait, I can't take this back?
Oh yeah, but what if...
Okay, I was gonna say...
What if I just go really, really fast?
Oh, I can't take it back.
Why can't I take it back?
Alright, I guess we go this way.
Oh, I figured it out!
I can't go back.
Oh wait.
Oh, it's a puzzle?
Wait, I know what to do.
I figured it out.
Ha ha ha!
I was like wondering what that staircase was for.
Okay, nice.
I'm so smart.
That's right, you thought just because you died in hell that your grave would be safe?
That's fucking right.
I'm so smart.
Uh...
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I know about the six-legged horse.
I learned about that as a child.
He gave birth to a horse and then his dad decided to use it as his fucking steed.
Which is pretty weird.
That's a pretty weird thing for his dad to do.
Not gonna lie.
The border is now open!
Come in!
Come in, everybody!
Hell is now free to come in!
That's right.
Nothing bad will happen now.
Borders are open to everybody.
There's no problem.
We don't have a...
Oh, I should not have...
I don't know why I decided to try and fight this guy.
Oh my god.
He was actually just chilling.
I was like, you know what, no.
Fuck you in particular.
Fuck it, let's go.
Let's fucking brawl.
Let's go.
I'm gonna kick your ass.
I could have used this on like, you know...
The actual boss fight.
But I could take you.
I know I could take you.
Oh shit.
I think I can take you.
That's fucking right.
Oh, you think you're good?
You're in hell, baby.
There we go.
Nice.
Red blade.
Oh.
Low perk chance to grant a gift of strength.
Oh, I like that.
That sounds cool.
I'm gaming.
Nice.
These guys are like little babies.
So like, I'm not too afraid.
Not gonna...
Impale.
Press.
Wait, what?
Oh, you mean like this.
What are you doing?
Get over here.
What the fuck?
Okay, that's...
That's a little bit overkill.
Get over here.
That's right.
And again.
Again.
Alright.
Nice.
You did it.
I'm locked in now.
Oh, wait.
I can use this to open the other area.
Wait.
Oh, I thought that was fire.
Nevermind.
I thought that was wind already.
My bad.
And off I go.
Oh, fuck you in particular.
Like...
I know that was my special move.
But fuck you in particular.
And you too.
And again.
Armed and dangerous.
Again.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, you think...
You think you can get away with that?
Hold on.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god, do you think he's okay?
Alright, nice.
Easy.
We go back now.
Oh, he is...
She's regressing.
God.
What the fuck?
What do you mean?
I'm just utilizing the best move in this game.
That's fucking right.
And again.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
I'll use it against you.
This is somehow a Marvel Rivalry.
Alright, nice.
We made it back.
Alright, I should be able to upgrade my...
Yeah, my Blades of Chaos now.
Yay!
Yeah!
Okay, now that I upgraded...
I can upgrade my skills, right?
Where's my blade?
There we go.
Might as well just upgrade everything.
I can afford it.
Okay, nice.
Alright, back home I go.
Boy, I'm coming back, boy.
Daddy's gonna come back.
Did you see what it does?
Oh shit!
Oh wait, that's not right.
I was like, whoa!
Whoa!
Okay, that's cool.
Alright, nice.
That's a cool spin attack.
Spin!
How do I go back home?
Oh, Midgard!
Sorry.
I was like, where's home?
I finally understand!
I'm dangling from the hip of the bloody ghost of Sparta!
Do not call me that.
Am I supposed to be allowed to see...
Like, see Zeus?
Or like, is that something in the future?
But you really can't stay away from him, can you?
You must say nothing to the boy.
He must never know he's Greek.
I'm so fucked.
He has to know.
He'll never be whole without the truth.
Look, I get it.
You hate the gods.
All gods.
It's no accident.
That includes yourself.
And it includes your boy.
Do you see that?
He feels that.
He can't help what he is.
He can't begin to help it because you haven't even told him.
It's all connected, man.
He can't know.
You will tell him nothing.
He can't know he's half Greek.
It will break him if he finds out that he's not pure blood.
He made it better?
What'd he do?
Well, he broke it.
If I didn't break it, then we can take it to Freya.
Wait, can I go straight to Freya?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I can!
I can!
Yay!
I can just walk to Freya now.
Finally,
it only took four playthroughs to unlock fast travel.
I mean, it's almost there.
It's literally next door.
What do you mean it isn't right?
It's literally right here.
I did it, Freya.
I got the heart.
I lost your boat, though.
That's so much walking.
He must not know.
Yeah, no fucking shit.
He's like...
He's white as hell.
You're a god, boy.
I'm a what?
Oh,
I killed him.
Oh, wait, no.
I killed your grandson.
Oh, that's awkward, man.
That's pretty awkward.
I guess I won't tell you who I just killed.
Is that how the medicine works?
Fears?
Feed the medicine to my fucking boy.
Oh,
shit, he's alive.
Boy, I have something to tell you.
You're a half-kreek.
I'm sorry.
I know this is a serious moment.
I'm sorry, guys.
Okay, boy, I actually do have something serious to tell you.
I'm sorry to find out this late.
I thought I was supposed to tell him, Freya.
What happened?
I'm not gonna tell him?
Oh, I might need, like, an actual moment.
I guess, like, I have to give him, like, a moment.
Like, a special moment.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
We gotta find a nice place.
Aww.
That's why you should've signed a prenup.
Oh, that's fucked.
That was, like, a really bad guy.
Press zero.
Nothing happened.
Alright, son.
Alright, boy.
Now that you're fixed up...
It's time to go back to the grind.
That is not a door.
I thought there was multiple doors.
I'm sorry.
We gotta go this way.
Alright, boy.
Oh, what's going on?
Boy, why are you so depressed?
Alright, guys.
I think this is a good place to call it here.
We got a lot done.
I think this is a good place.
We fixed the boy.
He's okay now.
Aww, that was fun, though.
That was really fun.
I really enjoyed this part of the game.
I think the Chaos Blades was really fun to use.
I would've wanted to stream longer, but my voice is dying, guys.
My voice is dying right now.
So I gotta rest up.
But thank you, everybody.
I'm sorry I started this stream late today.
I really, really needed that nap.
But I still hope you guys had fun watching, even though the stream was late.
I really enjoyed that chapter.
I really liked that chapter, because I felt like I liked the story behind that chapter in general.
So that's definitely one of my favorite parts currently so far.
Currently so far in The God of War.
Arcturus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not so fun fact.
The Blades of Chaos are eternally bound... I think it's a curse, right?
Bound to Kratos.
No matter how many times he tries to rid himself of them during his journey from Greece to Midgard, they always return to them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, thank you all for coming.
I wish I could stream longer, but my voice is actually dying right now.
So I need to rest up.
Hey guys, as always, everybody...
Stay hydrated, posture check, get moving around to get that blood flowing.
And if you're suffering me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!